this little millipede like robot is made
of plastic when powered by air it's a
simple design but the surprising thing
about it is how it was made this robot
was printed using a new kind of 3d
printer one that can print objects using
multiple different materials with a
speed and level of detail that was
previously impossible conventional 3d
printers usually build up objects in one
material bit by bit but this printer can
deposit two four or even eight different
materials from one nozzle and they can
do it at high resolution each of these
tiny 3d pixels is about the width of a
human hair to print complex patterns in
a short space of time the nozzles have
to be able to switch quickly between
materials very quickly and it doesn't
end there the new design can print with
multiple nozzles at the same time for
some projects this makes printing much
faster although at the moment every
nozzle has to be printing the same thing
to demonstrate the benefits of combining
different materials researchers made
this origami sheet which has flexible
folding edges in between rigid areas the
same principle applies to this beaker
carrying soft robot the tubes create a
vacuum that crumples the soft parts of
the legs
allowing them to bend and walk the
printer can also deposit a wide variety
of materials wax silicon and gelatin
inks were all used and the researchers
hope this technology could be used to
print things like flexible electronics
rechargeable batteries and even
materials containing human cells for now
though if you need a conical flask
delivered you know who to call
you
[Music]